know who Andrew Tate is he says like he  only dates young girls and he's what  like 30 something why would you go so  young do you like older men I don't like  younger men I'm 24 and I've dated like  21 year olds and it's not for me what  any like younger men they're just less  mature what if I said that's sexist that  you don't like younger men I wouldn't  say so  [Music]  it's the worst example for boys like our  generation what don't you like about him  why would it be bad for boys to be like  Andrew Tate  just like how he views women how does he  use women  um  oh my God I really don't know I don't  know what to say can you give me any  example of something that he's done  which is bad to women  I'm telling you I don't know what to say  so maybe he's not that bad